it's the best thumbnail we've had in a
hot minute in the opening scene we are
introduced to two close friends Jerry
and Mike who are talking about Jerry's
relationship with his girlfriend Lisa
both of them assumed that she has been
cheating on him in an attempt to seek
revenge Mike suggests that Jerry should
cheat on Lisa as well however Jerry is
uncertain about how he can do so since
he does not have any other love
interests Mike claims to have a solution
for this and takes Jerry to a brothel
promising him that he has something
special arranged for him this is already
such a stupid idea throughout their
Journey Jerry is asked to cover his face
with a plastic bag in order to create a
proper surprise for him when they
finally arrive at the brothel they are
greeted by the owner Madame Zora we see
that the place has an eerie and
unconventional atmosphere and the most
peculiar thing is that the escorts
already know Jerry's name following this
Jerry is directed to an empty and dark
lit room and is locked in from the
outside leaving him confused as he
explores the room he just covers a black
box with the phrase stick it in here
written on it initially finding it
amusing he eventually unbuttons his
pants and proceeds to follow the
instructions in the midst of this Mike
is shown having coitus with three other
workers in an adjacent room while
enjoying himself he suddenly hears
Jerry's loud scream causing him to panic
so without wasting any time he ditches
the ladies and rushes to his friend only
to find him lying unconscious on the bed
let's hope that wasn't the pain box from
Dune Mike assumes that Jerry is finished
up so he buttons up his pants places him
in the car and drives away on their way
back Jerry regains Consciousness and
seems happier than ever he also
expresses his desire to do it again
however Mike advises him to take things
slowly explaining that the so-called
special thing is a one-time event he
also mentions the fact that it was very
expensive but nevertheless Mike promises
to arrange another visit soon this time
with a beautiful worker named Sid upon
reaching home Lisa asks Jerry where he
had been and he simply pretends that he
was out drinking with Mike in a
surprising turn of events Lisa reveals
that she is pregnant asserting that
Jerry is not infertile and that his
sperm is capable of swimming this
Revelation shocks Jerry and he struggles
to believe it he questions whether the
baby is truly his but this only upsets
Lisa further the next day Jerry goes to
work and meets with Mike he inquires
about the location of the Brothel House
but Mike refuses to divulge the
information and tries to keep him away
for some unknown reason desperate to
revisit the place Jerry makes a search
on the internet hoping to find its
whereabouts after a short while he
stumbles upon a similar establishment
owned by a woman named Mystic Wanda
wasting no time Jerry heads towards the
sub location and asks Wanda about Madame
Zora the woman pretends to be oblivious
at first but when Jerry offers her some
cash she quickly gives him the address
to the creepy looking brothel ass
shortly after when Jerry arrives at the
place Madame Zora greets him at the door
and informs him that they are closed
however Jerry offers her twice the
amount and somehow persuades her to
Grant him access to the special package
for one more time then he is escorted to
the same Eerie room containing the
enigmatic box Jerry proceeds to follow
the same procedure as before dip and
Dong in the dark Dan satisfying his
desires while fully conscious this time
once he is done his curiosity Rises as
he wants to uncover the secrets hidden
within the mysterious box he attempts to
peer through the hole using his phone's
flashlight and even tries to open it
forcefully but discovers that it is
locked from outside moments later Madame
Zora enters the room to inform him that
his session is over but she finds Jerry
forcefully attempting to access the Box
she frantically tries to intervene what
if he finds out that it's baby Yoda in
there but Jerry consumed by his
desperation to reveal its contents
violently kicks her to the ground and
Stomps her to death after this he grabs
the mysterious box and hastily departs
from the premises he then rents a hotel
room for a period of six days hiding the
Box along with him meanwhile at the
Brothel House detective Barnes is seen
investigating the death case he focuses
on questioning Ivan the person
responsible for security and maintenance
of the brothel but Ivan claims to know
nothing stating that he was absent
during the crime as he went out to
purchase groceries the following day
Jerry is back at work but his mind is
disturbed by his recent sinful act he
simply cannot shake off the fact that he
killed someone after work he goes back
to the hotel and indulges in his desires
once again once he's finished he
curiously inserts his hand into the
whole of the mysterious box only to
discover a jelly-like sticky substance
within gross intrigued he begins
touching himself with the sticky liquid
which intensifies his pleasure
indicating that there is something
magical in the substance Jerry collects
more of the liquid in a small bottle
before heading home when he arrives Lisa
inquires about the reason for his
lateness and Jerry simply makes a
work-related excuse I was up to my balls
in it he says later that night he finds
himself alone in bed and attempts to use
the sticky liquid to gain pleasure
however at the same moment Lisa enters
the room unexpectedly and catches him in
the ACT thinking quickly Jerry comes up
with an excuse pretending that he was
about to surprise her following this the
two engage in coitus but Jerry is
desperate and aggressive in the process
causing Lisa to feel uneasy she did not
agree to a menage à trois with ectoplasm
the next day Jerry prepares to leave
pretending that he has a client to meet
sensing his unusual behavior over the
past few days Lisa contacts Mike and
inquires if Jerry is involved in a
secret affair Mike denies any
information but promises to inform her
if he notices anything suspicious later
on while taking a shower Lisa
experiences a sudden and sharp pain in
her stomach resulting in bleeding
probably due to the sticky substance
that Jerry used last night on the other
hand detective Barnes is at the crime
scene where he discovers some occult
books into Madame Zora's bookshelf Ivan
informs him that she used those books in
order to cast curses on people they then
proceed to the Eerie room and realize
that the black mysterious box is missing
back at the hotel Jerry is seen
attempting to indulge himself once again
by inserting himself into the box
however this time he is unable to do so
and instead experiences pain in his
lower abdomen hastily removing himself
from the box he discovers bruises
spreading below his belly button This
concerns Jerry so he promptly visits a
doctor the latter runs some tests
prescribes some medication and advises
him to abstain from regular intercourse
at least take a break from the [__] box
there Jerry after this Jerry cancels all
of his work meetings for the day and
returns home to rest unfortunately the
infection starts spreading to his
stomach region to make matters worse
Lisa approaches him with the
heartbreaking news of her miscarriage
however Jerry pays little attention to
her and simply suggests that they try
again despite the painful bruises and
medical advice Jerry remains deeply
addicted to using the sticky substance
the very next day he returns to the
hotel room driven by his obsession but
just as he is about to put his dwarf
star in the black hole he realizes that
the box is now devoid of the sticky
substance now that he is unable to
control his erotic drive he desperately
looks for ways to open the black box as
a result Jerry visits a nearby hardware
store and purchases a lock cutting tool
he then returns to the hotel room and
successfully unlocks the mysterious box
after this he retrieves its enigmatic
contents and proceeds to gratify himself
unfortunately the consequences are dire
as his bruises continue to spread across
his body back at home Lisa discovers
Jerry's credit card statement revealing
excessive withdrawals used to rent a
hotel room at the same time she receives
a call from Jerry's workplace notifying
her of his absence these findings
solidify her doubts that Jerry is
cheating on her fueled by her suspicion
she drives to the same hotel in an
attempt to catch him red-handed upon
breaking into his room she detects an
unfamiliar scent and assumes it to be
the presence of another woman with whom
Jerry is having an affair Lisa then
searches the entire room hoping to find
some Clues when she doesn't find
anything she enters the bathroom there
she shockingly discovers a jelly-like
moving flesh that Jerry has been using
for his satisfaction however before she
can question him about it Jerry attacks
her from behind and chokes her tightly
when she stops resisting Jerry releases
his grip thinking that he has succeeded
in killing her but to his utter shock
she is still alive in a state of panic
Jerry seizes a heavy lock cutter and
brutally strikes her finally killing her
in the aftermath of this event Jerry
meticulously cleans the blood stains
from the room wraps Lisa's lifeless body
in a bed sheet and transports it to his
car he then drives back to his home and
discreetly disposes of the body in his
garage the next day he checks out of the
hotel room carrying the peculiar moving
flesh with him then he returns home and
transforms his bedroom to resemble the
Eerie atmosphere of Madame Zora's
Brothel House once his setup is complete
he begins engaging in physical
activities with the flesh he's starting
his own cult called The Bone Masons
elsewhere Mike learns about Madame
Zora's demise and decides to check on
Jerry when he reaches the latter's
residence he notices that the garage
door is open Curious Mike enters the
house and heads to Jerry's dimly lit
bedroom to his surprise he discovers the
moving flesh leading him to suspect that
Jerry is involved in something nefarious
right then Jerry arrives home and talks
in a casual way acting as if nothing has
happened but Mike comes to the point and
tries to assure Jerry that he will
remain his friend no matter what he also
promises to cover up for Jerry even if
he is involved in Madame Zora's case
however Panic sets in when Jerry reveals
that he has also taken the life of Lisa
fearing the consequences Mike grabs his
phone to contact the police but Jerry
covers his head with a plastic bag and
suffocates him to death in scene we see
Jerry whose body is now completely
covered in deadly bruises but despite
all this he is still sleeping alongside
the moving flesh it seems that he has
become addicted to it suddenly the
doorbell rings and Jerry answers it only
to find his neighbors who have come to
celebrate his birthday however Jerry in
his deteriorating mental state shouts at
them to leave his property be gone all I
want for my birthday is to put my dick
in the goop he then returns to his
bedroom and discovers that the once
moving flesh is now lifeless overwhelmed
with despair he breaks down in tears
uncertain of what to do next frantically
he rushes to Madame Zora's brothel and
seeks assistance from Ivan the latter is
shocked to see his State nonetheless he
instructs Jerry to wait in the same
creepy room from earlier while he takes
the dead flesh with him as Jerry Waits
his body undergoes a grotesque
transformation his hair falls out his
teeth deteriorate and his skin gradually
morphs into jelly-like substance
rendering him repulsive in
meanwhile Ivan crafts another black box
with a hole inscribing the same message
on it before placing it in the creepy
room by this time Jerry has become a
sentient mass of flash shortly after
Ivan proceeds to detach Jerry's head
from his body and places it inside the
black box in the final scene detective
Barnes arrives at the brothel and
informs Ivan that Jerry is their Prime
Suspect however Ivan definitely changes
the subject and offers the detective
this special experience leading him to
the creepy room containing the Black Box
huh Jerry's [__] now subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching